[Applause]
Taj Gibson from the elbow karl-anthony
towns drew a lot of attention should be
Butler trying to take advantage of the
size advantage on Williams it does so
shoot me the last starter for the Wolves
to get into this morning column good
ball Jimmy little Euro step kick into
the corner Tyus Jones three and the ice
off the rim a little way to go wolves
Tyus Jones giving the wolves their
second mate ripple of the game early and
the sole team has to give it up bottlers
corner three drills it
so Andrew and Jimmy Butler make early
buckets here coming out of the second
half Jordan another rebound quick outlet
for Wilson didn't catch a clean and it
gave the turell's just enough of a
chance to get back on defended they've
had a problem of getting back in
transition Andrew Wiggins did a nice job
of making them
they knew that les cut by Jenny Cutler a
really good finish
with contact Jimmy just circled out from
the weak side and chrome right into an
advantageous position got a brother a
great name for a long and a firm that
look easy sure did
Butler son opening attacks fives Corki
Chang Georgie pitch the Wolves back on
top for the clothes were locking each
other up toddler [ __ ] rivers leaning the
wrong way takes advantage of a one
opportunity the middle of floored he
just reverses field on it that Jimmy
cuts the ball jumps into his body gets
the contact
Kotler [ __ ] has been here in this fourth
quarter
six of nine for Jimmy Butler in the
second half Butler has been huge in the
fourth quarter Austin Rivers matched up
on him the drive left and the spin move
back to the right throwing up over the
top of DeAndre Jordan didn't look like
DJ was ready gets it to go away
possibility for Jimmy single-handedly
will the Timberwolves still win here
tonight has done it all in the fourth
quarter as we go under a minute
Kotler
mr. Jimmy poplars show tonight ladies
and gentlemen so it's all good between
Jimmy Butler but he takes DeAndre Jordan
to the hoop here
nice move for the right to have
crossover
[Applause]